hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a german-american psychological
thriller mystery film called flight plan
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
it is a tough night for kyle pratt kyle
is an american aircraft engineer
recently widowed by the death of her
husband in berlin
she has to take her husband's body on a
flight to the us with her four years old
daughter
julia to help her with her anxiety kyle
takes pills as prescribed by her doctor
the next morning it is snowing outside a
taxi is waiting for them to take them to
the airport
while at the airport kyle loses julia
she panics
she sees strangers couples adults
but nobody kid-sized she turns again
there's julia over by a sundry stand
with an angry tone
she advises her not to wander around
without her permission
kyle and julia will soon board a plane
that kyle helped design
they are the first to enter the cabin
julia looks out her window
then she steams that window up with her
breath and draws a little heart in the
steam with her finger
a tiny clumsy heart then kyle takes a
nap
awakening from her nap she realizes that
julia has disappeared from her seat
kyle tries to ask other passengers but
none of the passengers recall seeing her
a flight attendant suggests that julia
might be playing with children of her
age
kyle walks down the aisle trying to find
her but still no sign of julia
kyle continues to look around with an
unease that's beginning to grow
she rejects their robe where they'd
fallen asleep she looks under that
blanket and finds the one armed bear
but no julia that's weird julia wouldn't
go anywhere without her bear
then she contacts a flight attendant
stephanie to help her find julia
stephanie agrees to help her and makes
an announcement of a missing child
a moment later however to her surprise
stephanie tells her there is no record
of her daughter boarding the flight
kyle is confused she is very sure her
daughter was there with her
so she tries to prove it by showing her
boarding pass
however kyle is unable to find julia's
and she also finds that her daughter's
backpack is missing from the overhead
bin
which is impossible because julia
couldn't have reached up here by herself
she's not tall enough seeing this
situation a sky marshal
jean carson begins to monitor her while
she's searching for her daughter
kyle demands to see the captain marcus
rich to get him involved in the search
for her daughter
hearing that there's no record of her
daughter boarding the flight the captain
asks if kyle is under any medication
right now
kyle says that she was taking sleeping
pills to help her with anxiety due to
her husband's death
kyle further reveals that her husband
died falling from their roof six days
ago
which she refuses to believe was suicide
the captain and the other crew members
suspect that kyle has become unhinged by
her husband's death and has imagined
bringing her daughter aboard
kyle insists on looking for julia from
nose to tail
captain rich reluctantly agrees and
orders the crew members to do a thorough
search
the lights in the cabin are turned on an
announcement is made to all passengers
not to leave their seats
stephanie goes down to the avionics
section looking around
but still no four-year-old girls while
pratt is busy searching
she sees an egyptian she confronts him
as she recognizes him from somewhere
she tries to remember but her brain's
too scrambled right now
kyle then asks the captain to look for
julia in the cargo hold
captain rich doesn't allow that and
angrily states that there are hundreds
of passengers on this flight who are not
receiving any
attention at the moment because all
flight attendants are busy conducting a
search for a child that none of them
believe was ever on board
kyle doesn't take it well she then runs
to the egyptian
she accuses the man of kidnapping her
daughter as she now remembers that she
saw him last night
staring into her daughter's bedroom the
man is annoyed at being accused
then he shows proof of her seat of the
hotel where he lived which is nowhere
near her apartment
then chaos ensues kyle forces the man to
confess
they fight carson who is fed up with her
behavior
states that her husband's death makes
more sense now a couple of hours with
her
and even he is ready to jump not long
after
captain marcus receives a wire from the
hospital in berlin that says julia was
with her father when he fell off the
roof and also died of internal injuries
now the crew believes she is delusional
kyle furiously denies it
she is very sure that julia is still
alive and still on the plane
carson now feels that kyle is a threat
by making up such a story
so he handcuffs her and keeps her in her
seat a therapist
lisa approaches and tries to console her
causing kyle to doubt her own sanity
she now begins to accept her daughter's
death however
she then notices that a heart julia had
drawn earlier on the window next to her
seat is real
kyle becomes increasingly convinced that
something weird is going on
she then convinces the therapist to let
her use the bathroom
instead of doing so she climbs into the
upper compartment and sabotages the
aircraft's electronics
deploying the oxygen masks and
interrupting lighting all passengers and
crew start to panic
but carson realizes that kyle is the one
behind this
she uses the chaos to take a dumb waiter
to the lower freight deck
she finds her husband's casket there she
unlocks david's casket
suspecting julia is inside but finds
only her husband's body
and nothing else carson finds her
puts her in handcuffs and escorts her
back announcing that the flight is
making an emergency stop over at goose
bay airport
where she will be taken into custody as
she's escorted to her seat
one of the passengers begins to applaud
the applause spreads
filling the deck some others are staring
at her including the egyptian
kyle reaches the back row where she
stops and sits there
kyle makes a final plea to carson that
she needs to search the plane upon
landing
carson considers for a moment then
decides to speak to the captain
however instead of speaking to the
captain he sneaks down to the freight
deck
there he removes two explosives and a
detonator concealed in david's casket
he then climbs down to the avionics
section and attaches the explosives to
the side of the platform
revealing julia who is sleeping at this
point
it is revealed that carson has been the
mastermind behind all of this
carson and stephanie have conspired to
hijack the aircraft for a 50 million
dollars ransom and frame kyle due to her
knowledge of the plane
they abducted julia to force kyle to
unlock the casket where he placed the
explosives in detonator
carson tells the captain that kyle is a
hijacker and threatens to blow up the
aircraft unless the airline transfers 50
million dollars into a bank account
carson then tells an unnerved stephanie
that he intends to blow up the plane
killing the unconscious julia and leave
kyle dead with the detonator in her hand
kyle still couldn't believe everything
that has happened she anxiously looks
out of the window as the plane is about
to land
other passengers are confused because of
the emergency landing
after landing the passengers exit the
aircraft
as the captain is leaving kyle confronts
the captain who angrily declares that
the ransom has been paid
kyle is confused by this soon she
realizes that all this is carson's doing
he uses the situation to twist the truth
and makes it look as if kyle is a
terrorist
realizing this truth kyle decides to
take advantage of the role of hijacker
commanding carson to remain aboard and
the crew to leave
carson hesitates but he realizes that if
he refuses
it would be seen that the charade would
be his as soon as the plane's door
closes
kyle knocks carson unconscious with a
fire extinguisher handcuffs into a rail
and takes the detonator from his pocket
stephanie comes out of hiding
carson regains consciousness he chases
after kyle shooting until she locks
herself in the cockpit
she opens a hatch door to the plane's
attic and throws out a binder to fool it
carson hears the upstairs thud and
leaves kyle exits and encounters a
guilt-ridden stephanie
she punches her who panics and
immediately flees the plane
kyle continues to look for her daughter
to the avionics and she finds julia
there
unconscious she immediately hugs her and
carries her
carson soon follows and while searching
reveals that he murdered her husband to
smuggle the explosives inside his casket
knowing that it would not be scanned at
the checkpoint kyle immediately carries
julia into the aircraft's
non-combustible hold
with the detonator in hand carson shoots
at her as she closes the door
with the non-combustible walls of the
hole to protect them she detonates the
explosives
exploding the plane killing carson the
passengers and crew watched the
explosion in shock
a moment later kyle appears with her
daughter as kyle carries her daughter
out onto the tarmac
all the passengers are shocked upon
realizing that she had been telling the
truth
the whole time the next morning at the
airport terminal
captain rich approaches and apologizes
to kyle for his skepticism
stephanie is led away by the fbi in
handcuffs wherein an agent informs them
that the berlin mortuary director has
also been arrested
kyle carries julia through the crowd of
passengers who realize the truth
all are stunned and somewhat
guilt-ridden for not believing her
before loading her daughter into a van
to take them away julia wakes up and
sleepily asks
are we there yet as they get ready to
leave
the final scene shows the egyptian
passenger helping to pick up her bag as
an act of respect and forgiveness
that's the ending of the movie flight
plan subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching